Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
They've been filming Captain America
4 and Robert Downey
Jr was spotted on the set
with the actors in scenes.
So we'll explain what's going on
and why he might have come back.
a bunch of upcoming Marvel Phase
five and Marvel Phase
six movies and Disney Plus series that
actually revolve around his character.
So even though he's not going to be in
every single Marvel movie
coming back for every single thing,
there are a lot of things
that are happening in Marvel right now
that completely revolve
around the character, which is funny.
if you're brand new to the channel, we're
also in the middle of Secret Invasion
episodes.
I'm doing giveaways for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your Robert Downey Jr.
Iron Man theories in the comments like
what is he coming back for in the MCU?
everybody wondering why would he come back
for Captain America for filming?
What's he doing?
is it a flashback
because he's dead in present day
and Captain America four isn't
meant to be a multiverse movie like a Kang
Multiverse War or Avengers
five Giant crossover movie.
There are a bunch of big cameo
scenes and actors coming back for that.
But Kevin Biggie, the other people,
they're actually making movies
that is meant to be super grounded
compared to the space based
in the more multiverse movies
that are happening the past years.
Like Deadpool three is a good example.
Extreme Multiverse.
Deadpool kills the Fox Marvel Universe.
I literally just did a video for that
because there were so many scenes
that have been posting
and so many big cameos
from all the different Fox Marvel movies,
like there's so many multiverse cameos.
Captain America
four is like the opposite of that.
Mostly just the Earth based main
MCU characters revolving around
an Earth based plot across Marvel Phase
five In setting up Marvel Phase six.
maybe there'll be a teaser
for the new Avengers team during that,
like an Avengers five post-credits scene.
But like, that's as crazy
as they would get when you're talking
about big multiverse stuff
the fan that spotted him filming scenes
with the other Captain America
four actors
so that they were filming around
what would be the Capitol building
inside the MCU.
in while he was there in the scenes
he was just driving around a bunch
of really cool cars with the other actors.
could have some flashbacks?
Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man character
to explain part of what's happening
in present day with Thunderbolt.
Ross Vale is the current state
of the government in the MCU
because damage control essentially Iron
Man's baby Loki, created that organization
even during Spider-Man homecoming.
More recently, damage control
has become a little more villainous
or more antagonistic in the MCU,
and they take control
of a lot of his technology,
like the E, the technology, the drones.
During Spider-Man, No Way Home.
They also become pretty antagonistic
during the Miss Marvel series, too.
you can already see that after Dr.
Strangelove spell,
after they basically erased Peter Parker,
changed a few things about the backstory
behind the Edith Glasses and the drones.
They've already repurposed the drones
and are using them towards their own ends.
that's
just meant to be the tip of the iceberg
there's also all the Marvel Phase
five and Marvel Phase six
movie plots that revolve around Iron Man
specifically, also Disney Plus stuff, way
more than just Easter eggs and references,
particularly the Armor Wars movie.
For those of you that were disappointed
that they never made an Iron Man
four movie, like there are a lot of fan
trailers for Iron Man four out there.
that's basically the reason
why they turn armor wars from a series
into a movie armor wars
and now essentially Iron Man four.
But with Rhodey being the main character
and just a lot of Iron Man stuff in it
originally would happen
is based on the budget
they planned for it
like they only want to spend
about $150 million for the Disney
Plus series, which is why some of them are
only six episodes because they run way
longer in actual episode times
and some of them are way shorter,
like one division,
which only go for like 25
to 30 minutes had.
They continue to do Armor Wars
as a series,
it would have felt a little bit
more like Falcon and Winter Soldier.
Like, imagine the level of special effects
visual specs they used during that.
But Because it's based on the Iron Man
Armor Wars story from the comics.
It's all about Val in damage control.
Bow guarding all of Iron
Man's most advanced tech
and giving it to Justin Hammer
basically pieces coming back
during the series in them
doing all kinds of shady stuff with it
And as part of that, they wanted to be
able to show you a ton of Iron Man armor
doing all kinds of crazy action scenes
and all the crazy stuff Val tries
to get Justin Hammer
to create with Iron Man Tech,
which requires a crazy amount
of special effects to pull off a crazy
amount of visual effects,
putting it way, way beyond the budget
of a regular Marvel Disney plus series.
like you can't do armor wars
and they just have Rhodey walking around
talking to people, not wearing the armor
for six episodes and then instead,
like a post-credits scene where he does
wear the armor.
Everybody would be so disappointed.
So Kevin Feige,
the Marvel people
pretty quickly were like, Okay,
we just have to really cut down
this runtime.
Like we're not going to do a 6 hours
armor wars movie.
We're going to do like a two
and a half hour movie
and because of that bigger budget,
they could earn extra money back
through a theatrical in a home video
release run, which I am totally fine with.
Yes, it is shorter,
but it's actually going to be the version
of Armor Wars that you wanted to see
instead of something else.
my other initial thought,
when fans started seeing him
and posting about him
filming scenes on Captain America four
was that he came back
as part of his new TV show,
like a separate TV show
called Downey's Dream Cars,
which is a series where he modeled
his personal car collection
with a bunch of different types of eco
friendly tech like electric and biodiesel
can't believe he actually has a car
that's based on Thanos.
he also wound up giving Chris Evans
a custom car right after Avengers Endgame
came out when he announced
that he was going to retire
effectively as the Steve Rogers
Captain America character.
So he has a massive car collection.
but it's no surprise that Robert Downey
Jr is a big car person.
all the people posting this stuff
though of him
coming back on Captain America
for where on their mothers lives.
It wasn't for his separate TV show
so will see recently
there was also a marvel producer
that made it sound like Robert Downey
Jr was never going to come back,
which I think is a false assumption.
I think the press just misinterpreted
what a producer said
using an out of context, quote,
what the producer said was
that when people were pitching new Marvel
Phase five movies and Disney Plus shows,
Robert Downey Jr was just off the table
in what I think he actually meant.
Was it right after Avengers
Endgame when they were planning out
Marvel, Phase four, Phase five, Physics,
regular movies and series,
like all the movies
that did not have Avengers in the title,
they were not taking any pitches
from people like producers and other movie
makers for Iron Man four, with MCU,
Iron Man coming back to life immediately,
or for a Disney Plus series
where he would be like
every single episode,
like a main character.
just in general.
They weren't listening to Big Iron Man
returns pitches right after Endgame.
They wanted as many new characters
they hadn't done before.
Introduced to the MCU with a few sequels
for characters who were still alive,
confirmed at the end of Avengers Endgame
I also think that Marvel
is on this journey now of they're trying
a bunch of other stuff and it lets,
you know, I'm excited for them
to see how all that goes and it's hard
to it's hard to project, now.
There are so many rumors still out.
The fan theories.
People want to see Iron Man come back.
Could it ever happen?
Yeah. Anything could happen.
I'm really enjoying.
and all these wonderful things.
I'm looking right down the barrel.
that's why a couple of years ago,
you were seeing
all those clips of Robert Downey
Jr saying that Marvel was, quote unquote,
trying some stuff when Marvel Phase
four picked up, as in trying to introduce
a bunch of fresh meat to The Grinder,
bunch of brand new characters.
did say
he had some input when they were filming
the Ironheart series
and when that character was introduced
during Black Panther.
What kind of forever?
Because the character
so tied to Iron Man in the comics in a lot
of what they were doing with the character
was riffing on Iron Man stuff.
But he didn't give them any big notes
on Iron Heart or ask them
to change anything about her backstory
with Iron Man or the MCU,
other than to tell Dominic Thor Thorne,
the actress
who plays
the character, did just do her own thing.
Not to get too bogged down in too much
of his Iron Man character's backstory.
So like, he was actually pretty nice
to her.
the producers of that Ironheart series
didn't give too much away
about how the series invokes Iron Man
other than to, say, Iron Heart
in the MCU has a complicated connection
with Iron Man.
So we'll see what that turns into.
they won't be releasing
episodes of that till at least 2024.
They pushed the entire schedule,
so everything's been delayed
just a little bit.
I don't think we're going
to see any footage or a trailer for it
till the end of this year
or early next year at the earliest.
I already did a first
look video last year for all the footage
that did get released for the series.
So I had a link for that down
the description below.
right now, the Iron Man Armor Wars
movie is supposed to come out
right after the new Fantastic
Four movie around summer of 2025.
If that doesn't get delayed again, there,
a couple upcoming series and movies
that will set that up.
Like right now part of the school
Rhodey storyline in Secret Invasion
leads into armor wars,
mostly the idea that while Skrull Road
was in control,
being the advisor to the president,
he used all of his access to Iron
Man's technology and inside the government
you know, once everyone in power learns
the truth of what's happening
with the Skrulls and Skrull Rhodey,
they basically take even more control
of all of his previous assets,
his Iron Man technology
so while the real Rhodey tries
to deal with the consequences
of what Skrull Rhodey was doing
as he was pretending to be him,
you also have Val Thunderbolt Ross taking
control of all this Iron Man technology.
look at all these dangerous weapons
that were in the hands of Skrulls.
We need to take that into our governmental
control now, through damage control.
we know the Ironheart series
will help set up armor wars a little.
And I believe Dominic
Thorne is going to come back
and cameo in the movie with Rhodey
I would also say that the Vision
Quest series will tie in to Armor Wars
because of white vision
and what he's become.
He's essentially
Iron Man and Jarvis is baby basically.
but the Vision Quest series
is more of a wandavision spin off
and there's a bunch of other stuff
like young Avengers stuff going on
during that
they haven't announced
a release date either,
and it might not come out
until after Armor Wars.
So we'll see about that.
Thunderbolts will have
some minor connection to armor wars
because of what Val is doing with her
total access to any resources she needs.
After Thunderbolt, Ross becomes
president of the United States.
She's already in charge of the CIA.
So she already has enormous power.
But I believe she's also going
to take control of damage control,
which is one of the primary antagonists
of the Armor Wars movie.
Like just the hammers
coming back for armor wars.
And they're antagonists.
but we'll see if anybody else winds up
being the actual real villain
of that movie.
what they'll probably do
for really big Robert Downey Jr
cameo scenes is wait for Avengers
five in Avengers six,
just because those movies
are going to have so many cameos,
so many big things, that'll be the place
to really bring him back in a big way.
that way they can have him cameo
as other versions of the character
without having to bring main MCU Iron Man
back to life and walk back his sacrifice.
there's also a lot of rumors about the 838
Illuminati having a cameo seen during
Deadpool three in that superior Iron Man
that they didn't feature in the movie.
It might wind up
being a version of Robert Downey Jr,
or they could actually do the Tom Cruise
cameo.
Seemed like
everybody thought they were going to do.
let me know in the comments, though.
Robert Downey
Jr coming back to cameo at some point,
which movies do you want that to be in?
Which series do you want that to be in?
we're in the middle of Secret invasion
episodes.
My full episode for video we'll post
next week after they release it.
There were a couple of new non Marvel
trailers that also released recently.
I try to do videos for those as quickly
as possible because Comic-Con is coming up
and there'll be a bunch of big trailers
coming, Ben Frank Arts, congratulations.
You're the giveaway winner
from my last big Secret Invasion video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channel
on desktop
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my Secret Invasion
episode for video
and click here for my Deadpool
three First look and even more huge
cameo scenes that they just revealed.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!